nuevo fue el primero sino uno de los
últimos en una jornada histórica en perú
el presidente francisco sagasti terminó
el primer día de vacunación contra el
cob y 19 en el país dando ejemplo y
aplicándose la primera dosis del
antídoto desarrollado por la
farmacéutica china sino farm el
mandatario de 76 años fue incluido en
una primera fase dedicada sobre todo al
personal de salud no le tengan miedo a
la vacuna
la una como se ha dicho es el mejor
escudo en la lucha contra las
enfermedades tan visibles de tipo que lo
es el código más aún nunca antes en la
historia de la humanidad habíamos visto
un esfuerzo tan grande que han realizado
los científicos de todo el mundo
colaborando y compitiendo como se hace
en la ciencia
un millón de profesionales de la salud
junto con policías y militares hacen
parte de aquellos que integran esta
primera fase de vacunación en perú un
país que es el segundo de américa con la
mayor tasa de mortalidad sólo por detrás
de eeuu en el horizonte de una siguiente
fase para vacunar a 5,3 millones de
adultos mayores con enfermedades
preexistentes me parecía muy lejos
la una para realizar este proceso
y me parece un sueño
y los lotes de la vacuna ya partieron
fuera de lima a otras regiones como
huánuco una de las zonas más castigadas
por el comité 19 esto mientras que
siguen apareciendo cifras que reflejan
la crudeza de la pandemia sobre los
gremios más expuestos según la
asociación nacional de periodistas del
perú en 10 meses
108 reporteros han perdido la vida a
causa del cob y 19 según ellos la cifra
más alta en el mundo